someone asked me this question so I
figured you could help me answer yeah I
mean live both between America and this
and Canada we've lived between both what
are some of the big differences that you
feel living between here and across the
world when you go down south in the
states it's a bit like let's stop we're
gonna start at the first stop when you
say when you go from your country of
Canada to the country of America what's
the difference first off which country
of America because America is like 40
different countries all jump up to what
have you experience in Texas it's not my
experience in Florida it's not my
experience in the DMV it's not my
experience in California it's not my
experience in New York I'm not just
speaking generalities some of the big
differences it's just so much safer
period where like you could live in a
major city in Canada and not have to
lock your door in a lot of neighborhoods
you could I don't sometimes I forget
it's not something I really worry about
you could there's a couple breakings
here that it's not that dangerous and
we're not saying that there's no
breakings and when it does not danger I
don't know if some Canadians gonna be
like yo yo the six even the sixth where
people yes
yes it's it's it's getting crazy in the
sixth Toronto for those don't know but
the worst parts of Canada
are the best parts of America
I feel like that's a John Legend song
[Laughter]
like safety is just different safety is
different yeah like there's a certain
awareness that I have when I'm visiting
certain places or when I was staying
when I was living in Los Angeles in some
parts that I'm staying at which is
different than here when I go to Brazil
it feels different you know it right
away and so safety you guys look at the
numbers too like it's just a completely
different ballgame but there are a whole
lot more people so I can't understand
that like the safety is a bit different
you know I mean there's a whole lot more
people it's more compact it's more it's
not though it's actually not only in big
cities
it's actually not more compact one thing
you'll notice about like living in the
states too is they're just huge City
sprawls everything is spread out that's
actually one of the big problems other
than New York like you go to Florida if
you ain't got a car you not going
nowhere Florida is crazy I lived in I
lived I lived out in Van Nuys for some
time okay this is North this is like
northern part of Los Angeles right I had
homies who were stayed on Hawthorne or
in Long Beach like and that's a whole
trip and you didn't call them we're not
we're not seeing each other unless
Thanksgiving we're not homies we're pen
pals
send me a letter
that's another problem like one thing I
like at least my experience here in
Montreal and even Vancouver I could
probably say this is like things are a
lot more Compact and the City Planning
is much more efficient so a lot for good
public transport which is another big
deal the public transport in most
Canadian cities not all but most is far
more efficient than what I've seen for
most American cities and that's part of
it's just City Planning it's just
everything's so spread out everything is
like sectioned off into neighborhoods so
you live in your hood you really live in
your hood you know what I'm saying
there's people who live in the same city
who have never crossed over the other
side what if we have hoods they have
woods so far apart it's like you're
gonna okay Mommy I'm gonna have to see
my friend
I'm gonna win on a journey oh [ __ ] I
forgot the ring yeah cause I gotta bring
the ring to Mordor on the way to
Brooklyn
so like even the people that live in in
there's so many people that say that
they live in L.A
and I'm like
where
when I first went to LA I'm like yeah oh
[ __ ] I don't talk to my fans I'm like
yeah I'm in hell I'm in L.A and my
mother was like oh yeah I'm right there
where you at I'm like you're not right
there
that's not even L.A like what the [ __ ]
are you talking about yeah I'll say
another thing that's um so we talked
about the play transport another thing
that's very very different cost of
living like yes we have our issues here
with cost of living and it's growing to
some degree but it's not like major
cities in the states no you guys the
cost of living is crazy hot be it
produce be it food be it rent like I
would tell people what I would give for
rent and my American friends like shut
the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] they get mad
hearing with my rent because I know what
they were I remember my prices when I
was living at Los Angeles and it's still
not comparable to what it I have here in
Montreal with inflation with all the
because I lived there what was it this
mostly maybe 90 years ago now
back then it was still substantially
more expensive than what it is today
here in Canada for me with all the rent
hikes that have been happening over time
so you can imagine the cost of living is
completely different and people don't
really take that in but when your rent
is really high you don't have time to go
do other stuff because you're working
extra shifts to be able to make your
bills you don't have a disposable income
to be able to launch your products or
launch your ideas or your businesses
because you got to work extra shifts to
pay your bills or pay any debt you've
accrue from school so having that kind
of financial flexibility living up here
allowed me to be much more creative and
actually start this YouTube channel so
those are some of the things that kind
of helped out that's one of the big
difference I noticed in terms of
constantly now of course some of you
watching like well in route listen we're
not talking about rural parts we're
talking about most of the major cities
that people want to live in and so the
experience in Dallas Texas is not gonna
be the same thing as [ __ ] Mobile
Alabama or you know uh Columbus Ohio
sorry Columbus Ohio sounds cool on paper
nobody wants to visit so
I'm just saying these are the things
between the major things I know is
difference
um there's one thing whenever I visit
the states I have a hard time eating
like food is
I have a hard time eating because to
find food is fine if you want junk yeah
but if I want good food like I don't
want every meal to have cheese you know
what I mean slack on the cheese on the
bacon on the double size triple sized
[ __ ] on the beach that's what
I'm saying bruh it's really that though
I will say your defense
we talk about blood pressure
Chick-fil-A's worth it I'm not gonna lie
yeah but I'm not gonna have Chick-fil-A
every day I mean yeah yeah waffle fries
Chick-fil-A is worth it waffle fries for
free yeah but you don't know the real
spots here I don't have to know the real
spots I don't have you don't actually
don't have to know the real spot there's
gonna be food like food deserts you
don't really have that out here you have
plenty of that in the States you you you
could go I could drive for blocks and
blocks and blocks and blocks and there's
numbers but but but but fast food like
here I can find a little something
something true even even in rural spots
I could find a little spot a little
something some [ __ ] Daddy's
everywhere in this [ __ ] yeah over there
yeah they got IHOPs and Denny's
everywhere yeah they change in Walmarts
Walmart's pretty much owned the small
City Super Center wild in itself uh the
good
um you could do a lot of opportunities
there to make yes financially
opportunities in terms of financial like
mobility and America is very very high
because there's so much money and so
much Capital if you got good products or
good business ideas and there's such a
huge amount of people that you can sell
stuff to amazing place to start up
businesses I will say
um having left Ethiopia and moved to
Canada I think the south of America is
the only time I felt Southern
Hospitality that kind of warm feeling
you get from people around you now
there's not everywhere in the South but
when I was in New Orleans which is still
my favorite city in the states
um I loved the way people talk to each
other when I was staying there so much
so my experience
um was really Pleasant I think I I I
like American people I know everybody'd
be like these I personally when I go
down there I enjoy my time around
America oh oh you know what this one's
so underrated this one's so underrated
it is one of the greatest privileges
that we have living in this country what
happened you ready for this one yeah
you're not ready for this one none of
y'all ready for this I'm gonna say this
and you're like what the [ __ ] yo one
thing that America doesn't do well that
we do amazing up here you ready tap
water
[Applause]
that's a fact yo yay
my homies come up here my glasses like
yo this is delicious what about that
yeah
[Applause]
yeah
no no no you got a point one two one two
okay that tap water is nice delicious
and I don't like if you don't have a
Brita filter or whatever it is like I
remember saying some airbnbs and I'm
like getting thirsty all the time and
the top water over there is radioactive
turn you to a superpower or some [ __ ] so
I'ma I can't I can't touch it but I come
back up here and I get me a glass
oh experience but then again and so I'm
always grateful every time I drink that
happen it's just crazy that you watch
you bathing out water but you can't
drink it
you know what I mean it's oh Airlines I
like flying you can't fly in this
[ __ ] country everything is so stupid
expensive yes and the states if you want
to fly within the country there's some
amazing flights and there's so much to
do the capitalism and the fact that they
have a good Market that you have so many
competing Airlines lowering the prices
of of fare so flying to travel from the
states is very accessible so right I'm
going to Florida yeah but I got my boy
Mike that he's in different place in
Florida I might just take a flight yeah
for a couple of days yeah because it's
worth it before it's it is cheap it's
cheap it's matte like the flying thing
that's a big thing it cost me less to go
to fly to Europe than it does to fly to
Toronto or fly to [ __ ] Vancouver you
get what I'm trying to say that's how
crazy our flights are I'll say this if
you like doing anything you could find
anything and everything in America yup I
feel like when you come here to the
North like yeah there's a lot to do but
not anywhere near as much stuff to do as
are in the states so in terms of leisure
activities Niche stuff you can find
everything over there whereas here it's
a lot more limited in that sense so
that's definitely if we talk about the
East Coast uh this is why I have one
thing negative to say about the states
all right sorry the girls
and and
big game and Montreal got the girls
if you go to New York
you don't like New York Women they're a
bit rough and the one and the one and
the one that are nice they speak to you
like they bet they man yo what's up son
that's cat what's up son this cat for me
that's cat for you I think American
women look great not not the not the
easy and then when we talk about uh uh
if you talk about Florida it's either
they're not from there or they're really
done up and stuff but yeah like
oh
y'all rough
and that wasn't my experience but that's
pretty disappear so that's what it is
yeah Hey listen you're about to get hey
yeah let me know your DM if you're not
part of the rough ones you know and you
better have an unlocked uh Instagram
profile
so I could testify another one our
politics are super boring that's one
thing America does better America does
politics way better than we do yo Andrew
short said some [ __ ] I mean over here it
was talking about Bernie Sanders and he
was like where he ain't got merched
because he was talking about Troy Hey
listen Trump got merged we don't got
Trudeau ain't got merch all you
[ __ ] are not from Canada like
Trudeau because you don't live here we
elected our first Brown guy to be the
leader of one of the parties and this is
the moment he became elected forgot how
to make curry breath I don't know what
happens with our politics are so boring
they remove any flavor out of any
individual they're boring so I will say
that's another L for Canada a third L
for Canada that America doesn't have to
deal with well actually we kind of
export it to you guys Drake uh he from
here but he lives in your country now so
I think I I think that's the hell we
gotta share
America made them popular you know what
I don't really mind Drake Drizzy
the world
that's one of the best kid ever tell me
it was really going high that was me
that was great that's great
I don't mind Drake Jersey Drake Kiss Me
Thru the Phone still nothing I don't
mind I might I don't mind I don't mind
he's the main
grassy I'll be great t
-shirt
I want to hide this kid from the world
of the world
that was great great
yo shout out soldier boy
you made that moment really good oh yeah
so those are some of the things so if
you guys are wondering about moving to
Canada we try to listen pros and cons I
just did off top ahead I didn't even
think about this so there's probably
more
um but yeah those are some little things
I think yeah yeah if you guys like this
breakdown or if you guys want to get any
corrections but I think everything we
said is pretty accurate pretty accurate
I'd be very surprised I mean I seen it
with my own eyes so maybe I'll feel
different you have a different
experience but if you feel different you
have to have traveled all right don't
come up don't come up in this spot being
like no our [ __ ] is better my pictures
better my trip is better when you
haven't traveled okay if you haven't
traveled if you haven't come up north if
you haven't traveled a bit around the
world stop you're not you're not even
part of this conversation I go to
America four to five times a year and I
travel all across man it's been long
long periods of time out there I love it
out there right that's why people like
yo yeah I don't hate it I think it's
amazing and it's all right I wouldn't
live there want to raise my kid that's
me personally for different reasons I've
saved some of them I already listed
before Oh another negative oh America is
a very diverse country but it's super
racially very
when I was in Los Angeles that's one of
the most surprising things like Mexicans
stay with Mexicans black stay within
blacks Asians with Asians and they do
not make and I'm not talking about like
they don't hang out they literally live
in sequestered areas where you do not
see crossover 95 of the top
it was a really weird thing to
understand like the racial demographic
statistically speaking and be there and
realize like oh y'all live together but
y'all don't live together no and so
that's probably another conduct and I
don't like that personally you don't
like that uh just because it feels like
it breeds into animosity between the
groups I feel like here we intermingle a
lot better than I see them they are
ghettos it's just oh what is this ghetto
what kind of ghetto ghetto yeah there's
a lot of mother there's gonna be maybe
there's gonna be pretty like one group
but there's gonna be other groups within
that and it won't be weird to see them
walking around yeah if we talk about
Park X you got some Greeks over there
but you also got uh all the Pakistani
and all the Indians and uh Sri Lanka and
all that thing you you got that but you
got Greeks you got Arabs you got a
little bit of and they all live in the
same way yeah yeah yeah so that was a
weird thing that's not the case in every
city in the states no but in some of the
major cities I noticed that was a thing
pretty consistently so that was probably
another con for me we don't serve your
car around here boy yeah so yeah that's
pretty much it anything else no all
right